tu connais l'attitude japonaise elle elle très
changé fréquemment depuis 1956 où
c'était deux îles alors nous sommes sur votre
Initiative japonaise en général
arrêté
quelles ont été les conversations
cette partie de la crête des Kouriles, puis nous
reprise à la demande de la partie japonaise
pas de discours sur deux îles après ça
la position japonaise a encore changé et la chose
déjà parti 4 peur mais la russie jamais avec
l'Union soviétique n'était pas d'accord avec cela
mais je pense que nous devrions
nouer des relations de bon voisinage avec le Japon
les relations qui vous intéressent
le peuple japonais et le peuple russe
fédérations
nous sommes des partenaires naturels dans
dans de nombreux domaines
toute une série de raisons ne seront pas là
perdre du temps pour eux
liste
nos amis au japon le savent
Voilà pourquoi
nous sommes prêts à poursuivre cette consultation
tenant compte des réalités modernes mais fondées sur
comprendre ce qu'il y a dans la stratégie
plan et le Japon la Russie sont intéressés par
signer un traité de paix